[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
one of the most important tools you can
develop and hone as a communicator is
the art of paraphrasing
paraphrasing is an essential tool for
communication it allows you to do so
many things
by paraphrasing what I mean is not
parroting back what somebody says like
an annoying young child rather it's
about extracting the key essence or
meaning of what somebody says I like to
think to myself it's the bottom line
the goal in paraphrasing is not to get
it exactly right but just to highlight
something
so as you're listening and by the way
listening is a critical essential
ingredient to being good at paraphrasing
you must make sure you listen clearly
and intently to what the person is
saying most of us are very bad listeners
We only listen to get the gist or the
high level idea of what somebody's
saying and then we begin judging
evaluating and rehearsing what we want
to say when you're listening to
paraphrase you're listening for that key
Essence that bottom line
once you understand what that bottom
line is you simply
say it back
in as concise and clear way as you can
a paraphrase by definition should be
shorter than what the person said
now paraphrasing does five essential
things for you
first it validates the person you're
communicating with when you paraphrase
back what they've said
they feel validated they feel heard and
that feels really good
second it not only validates the person
it validates that you heard what they
said maybe you missed something or there
was some Nuance that didn't come through
it gives them the opportunity to correct
or adjust what you've said so it
validates the person and confirms the
message
if you are presenting or leading a
meeting or moderating a panel the third
thing paraphrasing does is it makes sure
everybody heard what's being said it
gets everybody on the same page imagine
you're in a large room and you are
presenting and somebody asks a question
and they're sitting right in front of
you the people behind them might not
have heard the question so by
paraphrasing you make sure everybody
knows what you're about to respond to
when we're virtual same thing happens
we've all heard those technical audio
snafus where somebody says something and
not everybody hears it the paraphrase
allows to make sure everybody hears what
you're saying
the fourth thing paraphrasing does is it
buys you time
paraphrasing is what we call a lower
order cognitive skill in other words it
takes cognitive effort but not complete
cognitive effort so I can be
paraphrasing and begin to think about
what I will say next the question I will
ask or where I will take the
conversation so paraphrasing buys you
time
paraphrasing also allows you to manage
conversation
what do I mean by that we've all been in
a situation where somebody has dominated
the conversation maybe it's somebody who
raises their hand and asks a long-winded
question maybe it's somebody who just
wants to show you how smart they are how
much they know about the topic maybe
it's somebody who's just lost in their
their articulating what they're trying
to figure out as they say it in any of
these circumstances you can use a
paraphrase to regain control and regain
Focus extract something of value that
they've said and then move on
or pull a question out of what they're
thinking so you can answer the question
so if somebody's Rambling On and On I
might say ah that question about cost is
really important and then you can answer
the question or you could say cost
sounds really interesting in fact I'd
love to hear and call on somebody else
to talk about it
paraphrasing to my mind is the most
polite way to interrupt and to regain
control of communication
now I said there are five things
paraphrasing helps you with validation
of person validation of message it makes
sure everybody hears buys you time and
allows you to manage conversation
there's a bonus that's not all
paraphrasing allows you to reframe the
topic
now we have to be careful here I'm not
advocating for doing this I'm simply
saying this is a tool that you can use
to do this when somebody asks you a
question or brings information to you
you can reframe it as something else
now I'm not saying become a politician
and answer the question you wish you
were asked versus what you were asked
but you can reframe something to make it
a little easier for you to answer and
address as long as it ties back to the
initial issue let me give you an example
imagine you are selling a product and
somebody asks you a question they say
why is that product why is your product
so expensive
that's a tough question to answer you
certainly don't want to paraphrase and
say so you're asking why this product's
so expensive bad idea
rather you might say the value of our
product is question was about price
notice my paraphrase says the value of
the product is and then I go through my
entire value proposition and at the end
I say and because of the value we
provide we charge the price we do
so I answered the price question it's
really about value but I in the
paraphrase I immediately reframe it to
be about value again I'm not advocating
you do this I am simply saying that
paraphrasing is the manner through which
you would do that if you wanted
paraphrasing is an essential
communication skill I encourage each of
you to practice paraphrasing you do that
by listening and thinking to yourself
what's the bottom line
thank you
[Music]